what compromises can be reached to stop
the war in ukraine turkey is hosting a
fourth round of talks following previous
failures is a breakthrough possible this
time
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim zhum their three previous
meetings failed to find a breakthrough
now negotiators from russia and ukraine
have held face-to-face talks in turkey
to try and end five weeks of war
turkey's president says now's the time
for concrete results and a ceasefire
the ukrainian delegation wants to see
peace nationwide before any final
agreement can be considered ukraine's
also offering to declare its neutrality
in return for security guarantees and to
discuss the status of the annexed region
of crimea over the next 15 years but
ukraine's leadership insists territorial
integrity and sovereignty are not up for
discussion
the president of ukraine gave clear
instructions to a delegation we do not
trade people land or sovereignty this is
not a subject for negotiation here
opposition is reinforced concrete
supplied by international law in
ukraine's armed forces international
sanctions that have been applied against
russia and weapons that have been handed
over to us to deter the aggressor
russia's military says it will reduce
activity around kiev and chernahiv some
of the kremlin's demands include
recognizing crimea as russian and the
donbass region as independent rasul
sardar has more from the talks in
istanbul
as the new round of peace talks between
russian and ukrainian delegations
continues in istanbul serious
disagreements remains between the
the negotiating parties here ukrainian
side is insisting on international
security guarantees and an immediate
ceasefire to resolve the urgent
humanitarian problems however the
russian side has tougher conditions
russia is asking ukraine officially to
announce its neutrality which means
ukraine not to pursue the goal of being
a nato member russia is also asking
ukraine to demilitarize itself and the
officials here they said that ukraine
has shown uh to a certain extent
willingness to make compromises on these
two demands another demand from russia
is the denotification of ukraine but the
officials say that it's very much an
ambiguous term an uncertain term and it
is not clear what russian means by
dynastifying the the ukraine however the
most delicate issue here is the
territorial integrity of ukraine because
russia is asking kiev also to officially
accept crimea which was annexed by
russia in 2014 as part of russia and
also forcing ukraine to
to recognize the two separatist
republics in eastern ukraine uh dunyas
and uh luhansk as independent states and
the officials say that ukrainian side so
far has not shown any willingness to
make compromises about its territorial
integrity the official says uh the the
the
the the road is quite rocky but mostly
the success of these uh negotiations
these peace talks in istanbul depends on
how much russia is going to make to
retreat from its maximalist demands and
the limits of the ukrainian flexibility
resuserdar for inside story
all right let's bring in our guests from
near keith zelmayev executive director
of the eurasia democracy initiative
from moscow andre kortunov director
general of the russian international
affairs council think tank
and from london zachary pakin a
researcher in the eu foreign policy unit
at the center for european policy
studies thanks so much for joining us
today and um we really appreciate your
time
peter zelmay let me start with you today
so russian negotiators in istanbul have
said that in order to build trust it has
been decided to decrease military
activities in kiev and chernohev
is this from your perspective a positive
sign
i mean as a sign it may be positive but
once again what's the trust you know and
that that's uh going to be the case uh
the russian federation has been less
than uh you know trustworthy on these
issues even before the invasions if you
remember a few days a bit prior to
february 24th the russian side said it
was pulling uh its troops away from the
border then it turned around regrouped
and hit ukraine in all its parts with a
massive kind of shock and awe campaign
of bombing which never really relented
during this whole time
i think the situation on the ground is
dictating that vladimir putin somehow uh
you know re-set his strategy simply
because the russian troops are stretched
to thin the logistics are poor
uh they have suffered massive casualties
15 sixteen thousand and counting and
fifty thousand disabled uh you know uh
soldiers etc uh but once again uh what
what i'm concerned about despite these
positive signals that we're hearing is
that this is yet another ploy by
vladimir putin to try to win time uh to
regroup and to try uh uh to hit uh kiev
stormkey and try to invade it a second
time from what i've heard from vladimir
putin himself he remains obsessed with
the idea of controlling all of ukraine
andre cortunov you've said before that a
ceasefire needs to be a top priority for
russia do you believe that it actually
is a top priority for president putin
right now
well i hope that it is a priority i
cannot say for sure of course
the initial russian position was that
the military operation should continue
uh till
the ukrainian armed forces are ready to
surrender
apparently this position has shifted i
think that uh there are still some
military objectives that the russian
leadership would like to achieve
at least they would like to get to the
administrative borders of the uh
luganska and donetsk oblasts so they
could control all the territories of
these regions of course together with
the military formations of the two
self-proclaimed republics i don't know
whether it can be achieved
in the immediate future but i would
suspect that that remains one of the
goals of the military operation and that
was reflected in the statement of
minister of defense sergey shoigu who
maintained just today
that the second stage of the military
operation includes establishing control
or as he put it protecting the territory
of the dugansk and
of lugansk and donetsk republics
zachary and i saw you nodding along to
some of what andre cartoon was saying
there did you want to jump in
well indeed just to agree that uh you
know the the focus of the russian
military campaign is indeed likely to be
centered on the east that's probably
where the prospects are situated for the
most
gains you know over the days and weeks
ahead
the initial you know significant
breakout that we saw of russian forces
in the south appears to now be
proceeding at a glacial pace or possibly
even being reversed in some cases and of
course you know the situation around
kiev is at a standstill so i think
forget about it from uh from a political
or strategic standpoint from a tactical
standpoint it also makes sense for the
russians to focus most of their
firepower now in the east but even there
there have been limits to the extent of
their advance so i think that some of
that might end up shaping the outcome of
of these talks uh the question of course
remains how long will these talks
continue and how long will this conflict
continue and i don't necessarily think
we should be optimistic that this thing
is going to to come to a head in the
next week or so it could take much
longer than that still zachary let me
also ask you there are these reports out
there that russia may no longer demand
that ukraine be as they say denazified
in these ceasefire talks what do you
make of that
well i i think that that term was
deliberately vague and that's part of
the reason why it was employed at the
very beginning right it could justify it
could be used to justify full-blown
regime change in kiev but it could also
be used simply as a means of of stating
the importance of protecting the zanbas
region for example and degrading you
know ukraine's military capabilities
when placed alongside the term
demilitarization you know again that to
both terms i think could mean you know
many different things to many different
people my suspicion and of course you
know it will be up to uh to i mean
analysts and future historians to
determine this but my suspicion is that
uh you know basically vladimir putin had
this option of refocusing the war
towards the donbass as a reserve option
from the very beginning uh in the event
that the war did not go according to
plans and that and that you know the
regime in kiev did not fall so quickly
if that is indeed the case that he has
had this as a reserve option for some
time i think that that perhaps
contradicts this thesis that you know
putin is some sort of a madman or that
he's insane uh you know in fact uh you
know this this war may have been
slightly better uh you know planned than
originally uh expected um
as many originally concluded in the
aftermath of the initial invasion peter
zelmayev the ukrainian delegation has
said that they want to see a nationwide
peace before any final agreement can be
considered do you think that that is
actually achievable
well i i certainly hope so you know uh i
think ukrainian the ukrainian side is
more than reasonable it is willing to
negotiate its neutrality status it is
willing to consider the issue of nato uh
even the issue of crimea you know
obviously it's not gonna it's not gonna
be able to sign off on russia's
sovereignty over crimea but it's
considering currently uh freezing this
for the next 15 years and moving into
this process of uh you know ongoing
debates about the final status of crimea
i think ukraine has done what it could
short of you know capitulation i think
vladimir putin's campaign of terror that
is proceeding across the board across
all of ukraine is actually designed to
try to soften ukraine's negotiating
position that's why i'm skeptical that
you know uh you know and i agree with my
uh
colleagues here who have said that this
is still time to go to fully play out
and keep in mind there's another thing a
very important date is coming up may 9th
which is the victory date uh for for
russia and the soviet union's victory
over the nazi germany and so vladimir
putin has been pulling troops uh into
ukraine's theater of action from armenia
from georgia from tajikistan even from
the far east we've also heard uh reports
that syrian fighters and hezbollah
fighters who may be coming to ukraine it
shows you the desperation that vladimir
putin has in order to show some sort of
a victory to uh his people i mean he's
lost so much uh blood and treasure
already that anything short of some kind
of a um
visible victory will be tantamount to
his political debt that's why i think
this is like a do or die moment for
vladimir putin he is very much concerned
with his own political survival he's
even physical survival i would say and
so i think he's we might yet see much
more escalation and much more misery uh
before there is serious talk of a peace
agreement andre kortunov in other
interviews with you you've said that
it's hard for you to comprehend mr
putin's actions when it comes to ukraine
are you any closer to understanding them
and do you think that there are any
international actors out there any
interlocutors who could offer mr putin a
credible off-ramp to the conflict at
this stage
well first of all let me say that i
agree with peter that uh
putin and the russian leadership cannot
afford to lose they need a victory
uh even symbolic victory are even not
complete victory but something that can
represent it uh domestically as a
victory and this is important uh in
terms of uh a foreign
engagement i think that there are
not too many people uh
in the world uh who might uh influence
uh the russian leadership uh
maybe a chairman c zhang bin from china
uh can be regarded as an honest broker
because china has good relations with
russia but it also has good relations
with ukraine it's a major trading
partner of both countries it's a major
investor in ukraine
so i can imagine that some kind of
mediation services from china
could be received positively
in moscow i am less confident about uh
attempts to mediate taken by people like
the turkish president
erdogan
because erdogan
turkey is a member to the north atlantic
alliance erdogan has never
tried to hide uh his sympathy uh uh for
uh ukraine uh and uh uh i don't think
that uh he can be regarded uh in the
kremlin uh as a as a mediator as an
honest broker
uh there might be some other people but
there are clearly not too many of them
and i think that the task of mediation
will not be easy
zachary pakin let me ask you i mean from
your vantage point who can be the most
effective mediators going forward
i don't think there's an obvious answer
to the question as andre just said there
are a number of you know theoretical uh
you know individuals or countries out
there that you know for one reason or
another particularly because they have
good relations with with both russia and
ukraine could serve that role the
question is do they actually have you
know the political will and capacity to
do so so we talked about china having
good relations with both we've talked
about turkey being both a member of nato
but having also you know pursued
pragmatic relations with russia in
recent years you know carving out
regional compacts in places like syria
and the south caucasus and in libya uh
you know people have also talked about
israel as being a possibility uh but at
the end of the day each of them has
their own narrow interests as well which
make it very difficult for them to be
able to you know break out of the
current geopolitical stalemate right
china's a very good example of this
uh you know on the on the one hand you
know china does have its interest in
maintaining good ties with russia for
geopolitical reasons in the sort of
great game that is now emerging with the
united states but china you know is
still a rising power in some respects
and needs to maintain you know good
relations uh you know with uh with the
united states and and uh you know with
the broader western political community
economically speaking technologically
speaking in order to continue that rise
so china's in a difficult position of
needing to pursue its own uh narrow
interests and that's naturally going to
make china a little bit more cautious
and because of the good relationship
that china and russia have developed and
invested in over recent years i think
that xi jinping is also going to be
quite cautious about you know
potentially uh twisting putin's arm you
know and trying to get him to bring this
war to an end and that would require
using not just carrots but also sticks
right that would involve exerting
political capital i don't think china's
ready to do that i think that's
unfortunate because i think that
countries like china india is another
example this could be an opportunity for
asia really to have its moment in the
sun and to surpass sort of europe and to
inaugurate the post-western world but
because of you know these various
dynamics that i've just laid out that
makes things a little bit more
complicated and so i think we're headed
to a little bit more of a disordered
world as a result
peter zelmay of uh president zielinski
has said that he wants to make sure
there are strong security guarantees in
place before there is any kind of accord
any kind of agreement um who would act
as a guarantor and and how difficult
would that be i mean how tough will it
be
to to find somebody who would be
acceptable to both sides uh various
countries might play a part in this but
how tough would that be to make a
reality and who do you think might be
the leading contenders
very tough it will be very tough uh to
go by the track record vladimir putin
views any uh and every uh round of
negotiation uh as a stepping stone to
greater escalation uh and once again uh
has shown himself less than uh
trustworthy uh we also have the
president of the 1993 budapest
memorandum which uh ukraine was
guaranteed security in uh exchange for
turning over its nuclear is significant
in nuclear arsenal over to russia and
look where has it has gotten us you know
you ukraine voluntarily disarmed itself
and now it's in a very vulnerable
position to say the least so vladimir
zelensky has said that uh very rightly
so through his interlocutor mr arakania
who is his
representative in the parliament that uh
this should be uh a guarantee stronger
than the collective security article of
nato article five uh and currently what
is being considered is that these the
countries that would be guarantors would
be country's members of the current uh
makeup of the security council and the
u.n including
obviously the permanent five so this is
something uh in this sense it's
unprecedented it's a completely
different security architecture but this
just speaks volumes about the kind of
vulnerability uh ukraine finds itself in
and once again the you know untrust
untrustworth untrustworthiness of of
russia you know ukraine has to have a
very very strong guarantees and in that
respect i think uh talk about
demilitarization ukraine is a non-star
ukraine has to have uh you know even
more defensive capability than it ever
has in order for this arrangement to
work
andre cortonov would it be acceptable in
the long term to president putin if
president zielinski were to remain in
power or would the ultimate aim of
president putin be
to see regime change and to have
president zilinski replaced in ukraine
well uh
i don't know what kind of personal
relations
they have
i
might be skeptical about any kind of
personal affinity between the two men
but uh in my opinion uh zelensky is uh
the
the only legitimate leader in ukraine uh
you can probably replace him with
someone else but this someone else
will not have the legitimacy and he or
she will not be accepted by the
ukrainian population
uh and uh what is the alternative i
personally do not see any
and i think that uh gradually we see uh
more and more readiness on the russian
side uh to negotiate with vladimir
zelansky
we don't know what will happen
at the next presidential elections in
ukraine but zelensky has emerged as an
international icon if you wish
he is known all over the world he is
respected and even admired
in many countries so how can you get rid
of him
why should you do that
my take is that uh
russia will have to deal with vladimir
zelinski if russia wants to end
these
this conflict so that's the only way to
go
zachary bacon let me ask you a version
of the same question i mean has from
your point of view president putin
accepted the fact that if he wants to go
forward with this he's going to have to
deal with president zilinski or does he
from your point of view does he want to
replace zelinski
i i think that it increasingly uh looks
like like like it's the case that he has
prepared to tolerate zinski remaining in
power uh but i think that this has a
little bit less to do with just the
dynamic between putin and zelinski
themselves i mean it's been said on this
panel already that you know putin needs
to be able to have you know some sort of
victory that he can sell at home in
order to preserve his own political life
i think this has more to do with just
putin it has to do with russia itself
right russia for centuries has viewed
its identity vis-a-vis europe as being a
great power and being a term setter and
if you can't set the terms vis-a-vis
ukraine you're certainly not able to set
the terms vis-a-vis nato the united
states or the collective west
and so this is a fundamental question
almost one could say an existential
question for russia because it has to do
with you know what does it mean to be
russia
ever since the russian imperial polity
began constructing itself it has in many
ways sought recognition from the west as
a respected equal
and that has been one of the drivers of
russian national identity for a long
time uh so these are some very very
difficult questions that remain
unresolved in the post-cold war era and
that russia is obviously having a very
difficult time wrestling with just like
other empires like the british empire
and the french empire and others also
had difficulty adjusting uh to their
novel circumstances uh as well as for
the notion uh you know of these security
guarantees that are currently being
discussed for ukraine i think it's
deeply unfortunate that we had to have a
war
in order to come to a situation where
we're discussing a perfectly reasonable
albeit difficult and tricky but
nonetheless a reasonable proposal for
how to revise the european security
architecture or at least revise the
architecture as it relates to ukraine
and other countries that want to have a
guaranteed neutral status
you know i think it was pretty clear to
any honest observer that mindless nato
expansion had outlived its usefulness as
a fundamental pillar uh of the post-cold
war european security order simply
because it had been rejected by russia
and if you don't have the buy-in of the
continent's most powerful country you're
not going to have a stable or durable
order on the continent so i i take the
idea i take the notion that these
proposals are being discussed right now
simply the fact that they're being
discussed as a positive indication that
maybe in the future there will be the
opportunity to pursue more creative
diplomacy and avoid future crises
peter zelmayev you and i on this program
in the past have discussed how important
it is for ukrainians that ukraine be
able to try and join nato at some point
so
if ukraine
now says that it is going to adopt a
neutral status
in exchange for security guarantees if
that is something that is acceptable to
president zielinski how does he sell
that to the public is that something
they would be willing to accept
that's a very good question you know
there's still much appetite among the
ukrainian public uh
for even nato membership but this is
where you know politicians come in and
they have to make choices that are
at odds with the will of the population
the previous speaker said something
about you know i made a point about
nato's mindless expansion you know that
is a a serious topic meriting a whole
separate discussion you know uh i would
just say that uh for vladimir putin the
nato expansion issue has been a red
herring i think what we're seeing in
ukraine is nothing to do very little to
do with nato expansion to ukraine
considering that you know
nato was not coming to ukraine in the
next
few years probably enough of vladimir
putin to you know uh finish out this
term in his life from we're talking
about 10-15 years uh rather what we're
seeing is that all 19th century style
land grab land conquest uh that vladimir
putin has been perpetrating against uh
ukraine and so uh i think vladimir putin
the vladimir lenski voldemort is gonna
have to make a tough choice he's gonna
he said he's gonna submit this to the
referendum and i think it's gonna be up
to him and his team to explain to the
ukrainians the kind of compromises and
sacrifices they're gonna have to make
all right we have run out of time so
we're gonna have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests peter zelmayev andre
cortonov and zachary pakin
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
mohammed jim jerome the whole team here
bye for now
you